[Musique]
une espèce devenue assez rare selon les
sondages une fan inconditionnelle des
manuels macron premiers beaux jours de
sa vie mais c'est le football donne
l'amour
[Musique]
oui
donc en début d'année je donnais mes
élèves
enfin j'ai observé m en fonction de
leurs traits de caractère vous les
jeudis répartissez dans quatre maisons
différentes icônes religion dérouté vers
super idée de dire de faire des clans et
la ségrégation au sein de la classe pour
donner envie et l enfant vit là on peut
corriger un peu gagné des dons qui avait
la maison il y avait des maisons des
arables maison des noirs la maison dès
qu'on en fait trop chaud quand il m'a
dit arabes et noirs
il ya un point commun entre le
rassemblement national et la france a
soumises et c'est le grand non-dit et ni
l'un ni l'autre ne peuvent le dire c'est
qu'ils ne supportent plus leurs leaders
respectifs c'est pas vrai ils savent
très bien qu'ils sont incapables d'être
présent la république et le grand
non-dit et le dise en interne ni pro
français le reconnaître ce soir c'est
qu'ils savent très bien que leur poulain
n'est pas le bon
tu es un grand talent quand elle a
choisi de le répéter la vraie c'est pas
possible il a fait le carton plein et le
retard était trop important sur la
première manche 6 jeux vous dérange
pendant vos discussions n'hésitez pas
meira cas je dois donner l'arrivée était
laissé diarra que les uns parce qu'elles
sont des raquettes s'il vous plaît il ya
des règles ici j'aurais bien toléré
c'est que moi me coûte tout le temps
d'aller à la rencontre s'est compris la
règle c'est que dès que je vis comica
quand je manque jeunes ont bloqué de
rentrer à banias laissez pas détourner
pas de rentrer abonnés ont dit si c'est
pour venir directement leur dû rester
chez vous ça fait pas pour celles des
banques donc à dire alors la douceur des
petites poches vous savez ce que j'en
pense
non je te le dire mais oui tu veux que
je te dise pas forcément
ensemble elles ont créé début septembre
un groupe facebook laisser nos enfants
respirent et qui a dépassé les 4000
membres
elle recense les témoignages de parents
et d'enfants
tous sont persuadés que le masque les
rendrait malade
on finit par se taire même si on a mal à
la tête on doit être malins se cacher
dans les toilettes ou derrière nos mains
pour voler un peu d'air
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
as tu des amours
elle dénonce un monde trop pigier nist
on a une société qui nie la mort à un
tel point qu'il n'est même plus
acceptable qu'ils aient quelques morts
en fait ces quelques morts si on le
rapporte à l'échelle du nombre
d'habitants en france les chiffres sont
pas non plus extrêmes
l'humanité a traversé d'autres crises
bien pire
il m'en donnait durée généreux et
c'était comme incroyable je me suis
senti bien immédiatement
je veux que tout le monde ait le même
traitement que votre président parce que
je me sens bien je me sens parfaitement
bien chaud je pense donc que c'est une
bénédiction de dieu que je l'ait attrapé
c'était un mal pour un bien épargné la
petite braves populations
rené des visages de certains
chroniqueurs vie si oui alors qu'est ce
qui se passe est quoi la photo c'est la
bougie je veux que vous ayez ce que j'ai
reçu et je vais le rendre gratuit vous
n'allez pas payés pour ça ce n'est pas
votre faute si c'est arrivé c'est la
faute de la chine et la chine va en
payer le prix fort est ce que tu trouves
normal c'est ainsi par exemple il y ait
des cierges des trucs comme ça qui est
une sorte de culte twilight mais chez
nous c'est le dieu oui mais c'était même
état il ya dix ans on a le droit le
droit à l'expression patek coupé et
bennoo le droit add your house est un
dieu a créé une société de morts-vivants
parce que finalement on n'a plus droit
de faire la fête on a pu en mettre
maintenant respirer donc il ya plein de
choses qu'on a plus droit de faire donc
on vit de façon un peu automatique
donc pour moi c'est une société de
morts-vivants et moi j'ai envie de
vivante j'ai envie que mes enfants
soient vivants j'envie que la société
soit en vie qui a écrit la fable du
corbeau et du renard
allez-y me rappelle plus légal ajoute un
là je sens qu'on va rigoler mais là on
va voir un celle que ça sonne creux et
c'est qui ça sonne plein et j'aimerais y
aller 3-2
ok alors tu as dit à saluer fermiers le
fermier en écran je fermais oui un
renard encore bouger olala le nom way de
ma vie il est là toi tu m'as areva les
fables de la fontaine victor hugo les
fables de la fontaine victor hugo moi je
prends avec les fables de la fontaine
c'était le titre et que c'était victor
hugo et que j'ai plein de qualités elle
fut un très bon signal je te jure c'est
mon coin cuisine est d'accord par contre
niveau grammaire c'est pas la folie à
faire et pauline il faut les faire dorer
les champignons respect ou [ __ ] mais
non quoi ça qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
on fait pas des grappes les purs faire
des déchets pour moi sacré de l'enfant
c'est à dire qu'en fait quand je jette
bat déjà bas y'a des gens qui ont un
métier tout gagné poubelle est en fait
foi c'est sûr ça saute inter comptant
tous les gens qui ont un travail plus
d'alliés nom masculin métier qui
consiste à ramasser les poubelles
attention ne pas confondre avec power
bah oui clara hélas son dictionnaire
bien à elle c'est comme les mecs qui
aiment les grosses passe comme ça biladi
il aime les fesses de léa marie c'est
les gens spéciaux sexuelle ouais
du coup moi je je je pense en fait que
polluer ou même voilà jeté des choses à
la poubelle au mois sacré dompta quoi
gab c'est une télévision invisible on a
regardé la télévision ne s'abîmera pas
les yeux